friend of mine is coming out here
present the next golden boy last time I
saw him was in the wings of this theater
last year trying to break his Oscar in
two because he said his horse deserved
half of it mr. Lee Marvin
well last year I like to explain
something you know you can sit out there
and you're expecting the other guy's
name to get called and you hear your own
name instead you're going to a basic
status shot so when you get up here you
don't really know what you're saying
are you trying to tell us you didn't
split your award with the horse well
what would a horse do with happen Oscar
when he could toss you for the other
hand
what's a pleasure for me to recite the
impressive roll call of the talented
young ladies have been nominated for the
best actress and to present a whole
Oscar to the winner the nominees are
Elizabeth Taylor and Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf Vanessa Redgrave in
Morgan ANILCA me a man and a woman Lynn
Redgrave in Georgia girl
Ida Kaminski a shop on Main Street oh
boy now how do you make a selection out
of five of those girls huh please thank
you all legal and upright and the winner
is Miss Elizabeth Taylor
excepting for Elizabeth Taylor Miss Anne
Bancroft
umm this Taylor regrets very much that
she can't be here tonight I'm sure she
must be very very proud
not half as nervous as me I'm sure but
she thanks you very very much thank you